[Music]
what's up my name is Samuel Leeds right
now I am in beautiful Thailand puket and
in this video I want to share a little
bit about work life balance cuz this is
the thing people say all the time how do
you have so much energy how do you
juggle so many things here's how I do it
number one rather than working in years
than saying 2024 this is my goal I don't
have yearly goals I have quarterly goals
and every time one of my year finishes I
go away once a year I go away for a
couple of weeks somewhere beautiful to
celebrate while I did in that quarter
and I went to a vlog to show you what I
do when I'm on holiday how I spend my
money where I travel to types of hotels
that we go to and also what I read cuz
when I'm away I read a lot of books I'm
going to be reading multiple books and I
want to be sharing you the lessons from
the books am man puring is where we are
got the beach down here white sandy
beaches absolutely beautiful you got a
gym here you got a boxing gym as well
which is going to be great cuz I'm
currently training for a fight so let's
take you to my room enjoy like the video
and let's
[Music]
go this is all our space here we can get
prob dinners where our but will come
bring us all the food this just
incredible you got the little private
pool here I'll just sit here for hour
and Bre and just look out of all that
water look at that look at that
juice is this is that room yeah walking
wardrobe over here for Amanda one for me
as well also one of the things that we
love about Thailand Custer service is so
incredible like every single day when
they come in and change our bed they
leave us with a gift so they'll put a
little gift on the bed and that's it so
this is the room so today I think we're
just going to have a relaxing day today
reading books chilling at the beach and
we'll just see where the wheat brings
[Music]
us
[Applause]
[Music]
I wanted to see some property
developments in Thailand so I thought
the best way to do it is to find local
property developers and I found Alice so
she invited me to take around a building
s is this your first prop project in
Thailand yeah we have done some flips in
the UK of apartment flips but this is
our first Thailand renovation I'm
excited let's have a look around then
[Applause]
yeah it's a six bed seven bath biller so
it's made up of two buildings on
opposite sides looking at each other
where we're standing now is the living
area so the kitchen will be down this
end wow dining table and sunken seating
are you going to sell it are you going
to live in it or are you going to rent
it out on airbn B yeah we've definitely
been tempted to live in it but we think
now the strategy is just going to be to
sell it and start building our own
personal cash quot do some more projects
with that cash spot and then we can kind
of go off in
there this is the scaffolding here in
Thailand health and safety is a little
different here I think by the looks of
things talk to about the Fig then so I
know entire working bat to how many bat
did this cost to buy the whole land of
the entire thing so we purchased it for
8.5 million which in GBP is around
200,000 how much are you expect D to
spend on it before it's like finished
and beautiful and luxurious in GBP
around 100 to 125,000 £200,000 what it
for about £1 125,000 expected might I
might be a little bit more enough but
hey I know about so you're talking about
320,000 yeah in which is crazy so doing
you then going to own a luxurious
mansion worth I think around in GBP
around 500 50,000 something around that
Mark so so there about4 of a million
digital profit yeah exactly that's
awesome well I really hope that it comes
off and we have to come back and relook
at it once it's finished what been the
biggest learning curve so far that you
leared making sure you get the correct
arual plans from the Geto because like
for the contractors to be able to quote
you accurately for your budget and for
there to be nothing going wrong yeah you
have to get cor plans from the GetGo
that our biggest Le well congratulations
and I'll come back next year hope when
it's done if you do put a b you like
come stand man yeah i' love
[Music]
[Applause]
to
[Music]
just been to the elephant sanctuary in
puket Thailand one of the things I
didn't realize was I mean there's about
8,000 elephants in Thailand they used to
be 100,000 but they're dying off because
they're less needed and out of the 8,000
more than half of them are not wild
they've been captured and a lot of them
are used for like circuses and things
like that they're mistreated they're
basically tortured and used for
entertainment purposes what we in today
with in elepant sanctuary so where it's
where elepants have been abused by
circuses and stuff what they' been found
in Wilds that have like chained up they
take this s and look out give them a
good light and we got to see them
swimming in their natural habitat we got
to feed them it's a good time man feel
[Music]
good it used to take me 6 months to read
a book I just couldn't finish I'd read
it so slowly I'd forget what I was
reading I have to go back read the pages
again and then there actually my pastor
who made me read a book called how to
read a book and it took me about six
months to read it but since then now I
can read a book in about a day so I read
a really good book called what they
don't teach you at Harvard Business
School and the book was so good that I
got part two which is what they still
don't teach at Harvard Business School
so I'll be reading this I've got a whole
bunch of other books I'm going to be
reading as well and then I'm going to
give a little review of the books and
some of the things that I learned from
the books at the end of the video so
stick around until the end cuz that's
when the real learning
[Music]
comes
I'm training boxing but everyone else is
doing more ties I'm temp to the ti
Bo far today this guy is small his fast
and Powerful
yeah the best fitness exercise you can
do
buy any
martialarts
literally read every single one of these
books cover to cover while I've been
here it's quite it's quite a endorphine
release sort of feeling when you finish
a book so really enjoyed reading these
some of them I hated with a passion some
of them I absolutely loved I'm not going
to have time in this vog to go over
every single book cuz it might take a
little bit of time however I did a whole
separate video going through the books
in detail and explaining what I learned
and which ones I recommend and which
ones I definitely wouldn't and I'm going
to leave a link in the description where
you can check out that if you're a
bookworm like me you're interested in
learning what I learned from the book so
you don't have to bother reading them
cuz I did then you can check out the
link in the description so I decided um
to read this book but they still don't
teach you at Harvard
University I mean I didn't put this down
as my favorite I put the next one down
as my favorite but out of all the books
if I was going to recommend to you if
you're wanting to get into business I
would recommend this one this book it
goes through sales negotiations
management there's nothing in here that
I read that was groundbreaking or like
oh it's completely changed the way I
view life and business but it was just
really refreshing if you started out
business this is going to really really
help you with the fundamentals of
business I enjoyed this but my favorite
BX was this one money in one lesson this
was brilliant I found this the most
fascinating read quite a quite a slog in
a way it's quite a thick book and it's
not it's not um you know it's not big
print either so it took me the longest
to read this took me about about 2 days
out of the 10 days I was here to read
this this book talks about money money
doesn't exist it never has existed and
it never will exist money is just an
idea a concept that everybody plays
along with but actually money doesn't
exist explains how money came off the
gold standard and how money effectively
is just an IOU you know it's not even on
the gold standard uh he explains central
banks how they work I found this just
fascinating as somebody that is an
investor and somebody that is you know
student of money and what money is this
was brilliant so this was my number one
but if you're guys getting started out
in business this might be a little bit
heavy for you if you're not like a if
you don't love reading Amanda read read
this for a little bit and she didn't
love it Mandy what did you think of this
book she like this one the much this one
that absolutely brilliant get
[Music]
it what an incredible 10 days in
Thailand when I used to go on holiday I
used to dread coming back to England cuz
I'm like oh the flight and then back to
England where it's all crappy now I'm
actually looking forward to getting back
because I'm looking forward to the
flight because I'm on a beautiful Suite
look forward to get back to England cuz
I love England I love my kids I love my
house life really is what you make it
and the other thing is is funny cuz a
lot of people get upset you know well
how would you leave your kids for so
long that's terrible n cuz when I get
back on Fresh they'll get the best of me
you know it's not like they holiday I go
out on holiday with them a lot as well
it's nice to I always get get away just
to just the two of us but yeah man
feeling refreshed recharged and looking
forward to getting back to England the
best country in the
[Music]
world